when you were thinking of having kids
your mom was considering getting imposed
my mom yeah this was like eight years
before I decided to have a child but my
mom really wanted me to have a kid and
she called me up one time she was like
honey there's something I really need to
talk to you about and which with my mom
that was a frequent call I would get it
usually meant like I'm gonna redecorate
the apartment and you're gonna pay for
it but uh or some catastrophe had
happened and she needed me to hide a
body so I finally stealed myself I went
over to her house she was I was like Mom
what is it and she was like well the
most amazing thing happened I went to
the gynecologist the other day my
preface is this my mom was 85 at the
time and I was like okay yeah and uh and
she said she told me the most amazing
thing she told me I could still bear a
child and I said and with my mom you
couldn't have a reaction you could you
had to be supportive so and uh so I
perfected people ask me like how do you
have this like not react on air I've
spent my life not reacting to my mom's
crazy statements so she said isn't that
amazing I said yes Mom I think that is
amazing that a gynecologist told you
that at age 85 you could still bear a
child I think that's amazing and she
said I said and then I'm immediately
thinking how do I stop my mom from
burying a child and which is a thought
I'm sure we've all had and I uh and so I
started saying like you know Mom I just
you know I'm just not sure it's a good
idea for you it's very you know labor
intensive no pun intended you know let's
see at 85 the child when you turned when
he's when the child is 20 you'll be what
105. the math on that just doesn't seem
good mom and finally she said I'm not
thinking about burying a child myself I
was like okay great she said uh you know
she was like you know you can get an egg
anywhere nowadays I was like uh-huh she
was like well what I was thinking is you
get an egg and you know fertilize it
with your sperm and I'll carry your
child oh my God you must have been
flipping the [__] out I said I said Mom
I love you but even for you this is
batshit crazy how great would that have
been if you impregnated your mother
you'd be out of the noise
whatever it would be your sperm
shouldn't be anywhere near your mind it
would be very disturbing
foreign